so in the last year and ten months
you've built up a seven million pound
property portfolio you came to the uk
with nothing under underdog i told you
you dominated bro dominate in london you
found a deal yes you approached a
mortgage broker and you said could i get
finance on this and he said i could
personally maybe partner with you yes
and let's do two straight away
what's the best way to build a good
relationship with a mustang
buy
to buy property like a mania there is no
animal like
so welcome to my house and
congratulations on your huge massive
success in this interview i wanted to
pick your brain on how you're finding
deals how you've managed to raise
millions of pounds what's your portfolio
worth of a minute seven million around
the seven million seven million yes and
you started 14 15
flats in london yeah
bedroom flat each one when did you get
your first property in london a year and
10 months ago so in the last year and 10
months you've built up a 7 million pound
property portfolio how have you managed
to finance such a massive so on the
first three i was putting my own equity
together with the investors and then i
realized that they wants to buy more
but i didn't have any equity anymore and
you run out of money i ran out of money
and i saw that they don't mind to put
this money on my deals
and get it back yeah when we finance
and uh that start the no money down deal
journey for me that since then i didn't
put any any penny on when did we meet
was it about two years ago yes and you
went you paid for training you went on
the bar refurbishing finance yes took
all the information very very quick
quick like in around two or three months
as much as i could yeah and i go out and
start with offers
did it big style bro and now you know
like we'll pick each other's brain like
you've got a construction company yes
which i think helps you oh yeah
definitely because you knew about the
build side the construction it's that's
my add value when when i was offering my
deals to investors because basically our
cost of build is yeah and hey i don't
want to go into too much detail on this
because i know that we want to focus on
the positive but you started with
nothing yes you know i mean back in
israel yeah i came here nine years ago i
was starting as a labor in the
construction
and worked for three years in this
company i was manager there and i
basically learned everything i needed
then i opened my own construction
company
work for a few years
save some equity and this is how i start
my journey with the property so when
you're looking for a deal now in 2022
what are you looking for and where are
you finding these deals because the
market's popping right now so where are
you finding your deals to be honest i'm
i'm searching only in two neighborhoods
that are one next to another that i live
in it so it's basically all like few
minutes around me the deals i'm looking
for
is the deals that i can fit hundred
percent uh
expenses in 75 from the end value that's
the magic
in drr so you're buying houses you're
pushing the value up you're then
refinancing them yes and you're doing
that with partners who are putting the
money in exactly okay so tell me about
some of your deals and i've been round
to many of your houses yeah and i can
vouch for you as a builder i can vouch
for you as a bi refurbishing finance
champion like i've seen with my own eyes
thank you what you're doing and we've
done we've done business together we've
yeah we've got
um you know we we're almost neighbors
you just live half an hour away from
from where i live yeah so you're
whereabouts are you based in london high
base in edgewater in edgewater north
west london yeah the last one you've
come to visit together with jordan from
love island yeah it was the last one
yeah and i bought it at the end
and it was a funny situation there can
learn from it i was dealing with the
banks i gave offer it got accepted and i
start to deal with the banks for good
offer
one bank came and say yeah the the house
uh worth one million not 1.1 million
and they offer
less than what we needed and the second
bank came you say it's worth even more
but the rent will be
smaller than what you think so it took
us time to find a good deal from the
bank and in this time the seller that
was
very stressed suddenly one day
called and say
let's exchange this week i will drop
100k
so me and my personal like all right of
course let's exchange
we was like just searching for a good
deal it's not that we was thinking to
cancel the deal or anything like that
and it was so much pressure from the
other side that i told to my wife i
think i'm losing this deal it's just not
going to happen they're too stressful
there they're not going to believe we're
going to buy the property they're
probably going to put it back online and
and suddenly the the exact opposite
happened that they come with a huge drop
of the price and and we took it in 1
million at the end so you bought it from
millions yeah so it's a million for the
purchase like i think it's around 60 for
the stamp duty
and
like 400 for the build let's call it all
together 1.5 when the gdp is 2 million
so you've got about 25 net profit
definitely yes and all the money out
plus 25 net profit in equity but it's
like half a million so really
interesting about your business model
and what you do is
you're making very good money and you've
got a very big portfolio but rather than
buying lots and lots and lots of houses
you're just going for bigger deals
bigger deals yes why do you do that
saving time yeah it's helped me to grow
my portfolio way quicker
if i can do four
or five
projects in the same time or in a year i
would love to have bigger projects and
finish with the bigger uh
results
because if you like
for instance take the bio refurbish your
finance strategy if you're living in
liverpool you can buy a house for fifty
thousand oh so i would do buildings
straight away yeah yeah but it's my
point because it's a game of numbers not
about what what you basically buying
yeah but if you buy something for 50 000
and then spend 25 000 doing it up and
then the end value is 100 yes you've
made 25 net profit yes which is the same
net profit as you're making the
difference is
it's gonna take you probably just as
long same amount of effort same amount
of work why would you do a 50 000 pound
house when you can do a 500 000 pound
house or a 1 million pound house same
amount of time same amount of work but
you're making 10 20 30 times the profit
and then why do one if you can find the
property they could split into four
so you can do it even yeah four times
more and that's what i'm looking to do
one of the things is what i've seen you
do really successfully is buy apartments
and then create an extra room yeah i'm
doing one right now yeah what about that
one that you showed me about six months
ago the apartment that you bought and
then you added an extra room and then
refinanced it what were the figures on
that that's uh like around 440 450
investment altogether
600 new value
so yeah the one i'm doing now it's the
same it's amazing
it's the first floor in a house that'd
been split many years ago i'm taking it
open the space and i'm adding another
room in the loft so i know the area i
know the pricing of the of the gdv
very very easy to control so are you
buying your deals are they
from estate agents are you doing state
agents zoopla i don't do any marketing
so you just get them all from agents all
from agents what's the best way to build
a good relationship with an estate agent
bye
when you buy from them yes
right yes then they call you
with new deals they know that you are
there they know that you are serious and
i saw the relationship you had with the
estate agent because i've met many of
you i've met i've met multiple of your
estate agents you've worked with and
they all sing your praises um
because you buy from them yes and that's
what they want they want a sale so if an
estate agent sells a deal to you and
you're quick and you buy it and you buy
cash and it goes through and they get
their commission when another good deal
comes along they're going to call you
yeah so there is an agent that they
bought more than one property already
from there also i give back now the
property back to them
to manage to rent out or to manage
so they keep it in the system they
obviously have interest to give you
means yeah
so talk to me then about how do you
raise finance because that's a scale
i believe that after a few deals that
you've done with with the investor you
don't need to find any more investors i
mean if you have good brr deal with 100
out you refinance money is now back on
the table if the investor will tell you
okay give me back my money
something is wrong
because obviously he wants to leave it
there and to make more deals on the same
money that he started with because if he
was trusting you on the first one on the
second one for sure he will trust your
work yeah so it's easier so after a few
of those you better basically have
people waiting for deals another thing
as well that you read them well is
you know your patch you know your area
you understand the planning rules really
well we will be walking around the
streets and you'll just be saying yeah
i'll we can get plans to do this to this
i understand the planning rules i know
what the council want i know the types
of properties they're looking for yeah
this street has got a history of doing
this this this like you're very very
familiar with the area that you're in
because a very small area i chose one
expensive small area why expensive
because as you say if you already build
and you already spend your your or your
money to renovate you want each meter
that you build
to have the highest value
at the end of the project so you can
have same project a neighborhood next to
a neighborhood and in here you will have
20 percent more than than here so this
game is also very important and you do
your properties very high-end yeah i
will call it medium plus
beautiful looks good though yeah quartz
in every kitchen you're not you're not
talking howden's kitchens no no no
german kitchen high end high-end but but
not much
yeah yeah so okay talk to me then about
right now 2000 you know you've seen my
financial freedom challenges where i
start all over again from scratch right
now you're in a position whereby you've
got relationships with agents you've got
your investors they're passing your
deals cool
what would you do
if i dumped you into my hometown
right in wolverhampton yeah
and you had no investors
no money no connections
and you and you're literally starting
from scratch
right now you're in wolverhampton what
do you do so obviously if you're finding
deals then you have a few options you
can either sell them as a as a pack
or you can find an investor and stay in
i believe that brr 100
out in refinance that's the best thing
you can find in in the whole real estate
world and investors just cannot cannot
resist it
that that's the best investment you can
find yeah it is there's nothing like it
so basically all right for someone
that's watching this it's not super
familiar with what buy refurbished
refinance is how it works explain it to
me
in a just in a very
shallow way to explain it if you buy a
house in 100k and you spend 50k on it to
renovate it put more meters in it brand
new house showers kitchens
and extension and loft whatever you add
to into it and you succeed to push the
new value to 200
then the bank will lend you 75 from the
200 that it's 150 that it's the money
that you basically invested so you can
take it
pay the first mortgage pay yourself
whatever you paid for the renovation and
the stamp duty and you can do it all
over again so you're recycling your
money yeah also when you get it back
obviously it's free of tax and
because most people think that you need
to get a job
work hard
save up money
and then invest into property then do it
again save up money buy a house save up
money
style old style style but you will never
be able to do the second one because you
can take too long to save yeah unless
you happen to be a premier league
football player i didn't save another
start since i started just from
yeah did you save quite a bit of money
from your construction company like 100
150 grand it started with 150 if you
were couldn't rewind back time would you
even bother doing that or would you go
straight to investors i would go
straight to investors i just i didn't
know
what's the value of what i have in my
hands what i respect about what you've
done is you kind of a lot of people that
are very successful in property you know
they've had so much opportunities
they've had money passed down to them
from their parents you built everything
from scratch bro you came to the uk with
nothing i'm the underdog i told you when
you first came to the uk
were you getting paid i get i got paid
70 pound per day and i used to pay back
to the guy
that i used to work for he lent me money
before so i used to pay him back 30.
yeah and i used to go home with 40 pay
the bus pay cigarettes but basically i
used to make nothing
that was my beginning and yeah this is
where i mean
always plan the next step so what would
your advice be
to someone
wanting to learn
and get into property in the way that
you have done anyone can do it anyone
can make like very quick uh growth
by finding brr deals good ones and then
that's it that's it you find one two
three investors that will fight between
them on those deals
and you don't need any more if you can
find it you can find it people people
think and this is really interesting
what you just said because i have people
of course every day coming to me asking
me questions about property right and
everybody thinks that the biggest
problem that they have
is that they don't have any money
now i think that getting the money is
the easy bit
the hard bit is getting the deal yeah
the deal or maybe in the beginning to do
first d a few deals that you can say
i've done my uh
proof of concept
this is what i've done yeah then it's
maybe become a little bit easier
but when the deal is right and you're
talking with the right investor that he
know the game
you come with nothing new to him you
just need to see the the figures the
property the the numbers yeah and take a
decision
when you're raising finance who are
these investors are they are they
um property investors already are they
business people first time i went to one
of my customers
that is a mortgage broker to get a
mortgage and he straight away
convinced me to do the deal with me
so hold on let me just get this right
you found a deal yes you approached a
mortgage broker yeah and you said could
i get finance on this and he said
i could personally maybe partner with
you yes and let's do two straight away
so we started like that and then i i
still had like half a budget for another
one they didn't
so i went to search for a bridge
and the bridger that i went to he was
the same like why why do you need a
bridge let me invest with you
and that's my investor that he bought
after like many properties with me while
he putting all the money now thanks god
i find a very big investor
that is not doing a jv with me but we
open like a strategic partnership that
we're going to do all together all my
investments everything is going to
finance it i'll have a salary so i'm
going to get paid basically for whatever
i like to do and do anyway
and uh yeah that that's basically the
the end goal
when you play this game
and now what i need yeah is lots of big
deals yeah what's your
strongest reason for doing this
the stronger truth i don't know i i quit
early from school was always running
in front of everyone not to stay behind
and
you know this kind of stuff i believe
and also i love properties it's
interesting for me it combined the
construction that i'm doing anyway
uh basically i'm building something huge
that i couldn't build in any other way
something that will stay long after me
hopefully what's the hardest aspect to
running this property investment
business i think the days before
completion i was like yeah i want it to
happen i want this to be behind me that
that's the the you know those this kind
of stress you know
or is the investor gonna actually
transfer the money or just playing game
yeah this can be a little bit stressful
how do you structure your deals with the
investors so if if let's say you found a
really good deal million pounds
it needs half a million pound spending
on it end value two million that's the
kind of deal that you find regularly yes
you find the deal let's say i've got
money and i'm interested what's what's
the structure so at the moment it's my
deal i have hundred percent i'm willing
to let you to invest in it
and share 50 50 with me so i'm going to
put the money in yes but do i have any
ownership yeah 50 we open a like a
shared company okay so we open a company
yeah we're gonna call the company samuel
and reggie yeah state's limited i'm
gonna put the money in how am i gonna
put the money like as a director's loan
exactly the right one so i'm gonna lend
my money to the company yes and then the
company is gonna buy and then any profit
well firstly i'm going to get my money
back and then any profit moving forward
the rent the capital appreciation the
uplift is 50 50. yeah as well as the
other property that will be purchased
with the returned money because
basically investor
happy investor would not take his money
out he wants his money to keep growing
yeah because if if if we double our
money i'm not going to go
my money back yes okay let's do it again
and in brr people need to understand is
hundred percent when you take out and
still you have a plus minus hundred
percent that stay
in equity it's 200
in a year
there is no animal like it
in the whole animal kingdom
what would you say the risks are well
obviously you need to know the gdv
what's the gdp the gdp is the end value
of the product that you finish to build
if you make a mistake in this one is
change the whole picture yeah so that's
very very important so in other words
once i've split this up into flats or
whatever i'm doing with it i've added
the bedroom i've added the loft the
extension
how much is this going to be worth how
do you know that how do you know the
figure you do due diligence right in
area
you learn it i i already know it by hard
because i work in a very small area so
when you look at like comparables speak
to agents maybe even pay a value or to
give you a valuation yes and
when you already have property so you've
done valuations you know you know what
the bank will give you on those
properties there is another
thing can put you in the risk is if you
miscalculate the build cost if you
miscalculate the build cost or if you
didn't really ask the contractor
to do what you imagine
and only basic stuff surprises will
occur that's why it's important to have
a good team
yes good builders good valuers
solicitors have you had any deals i've
lost money
no they've all my money they're all made
hundred percent out i'm i'm very careful
on the deals i'm choosing it's not that
i every few days find the deal what did
you think when you first like when did
the penny drop
about actually
i can i can add value and then i can
refinance like when did you
really grasp
the strategy oh yeah you get all the
credits to be honest because in the in
the beginning of the vid
i was wondering okay what's going to
happen now people are closing themselves
i'm not going to have a lot of work as a
contractor
maybe i should search
how to invest my 150k that i saved at
the time
and as soon as i put property uk
i saw your first video after a few of
them i saw the brr and i was shocked i
was just shocked
from what you are telling me
and after the search
i saw that it's actually real got deep
into it watched any video you have on
online
and yeah i was ready after two months i
went and start put offers and what made
me put offers so quickly is that i heard
you once say that when you go to rent
they ask you for references deposit
straight away but when you go to put
offer on the house nobody except to get
anything until
exchange day that it's three months
later yeah and until then you not
own nobody nothing there is no risk yeah
because you're putting an offer forward
when your offer has been accepted then
go find the money yes that's how i've
done all of them yeah first i've done i
got offer accepted
only then i find the investor how did
you justify because i know you went
through um at the time we were running
the mentorship online and you and you
did that and you also did the bio focus
rights master class which again is is
not a few hundred pounds it's in the
thousands how did you justify
that expense
when i think the result talk no
i don't justified anything the results
speak for themselves you cannot do it
without know what you're doing i always
say i wish somebody would have just
pointed me 10 years ago and tell me
have a look look what they've doing over
there yeah
and but now that you've taken things to
a whole new level because you're not
just doing biorefurbish your finance
you're actually getting planning
permission and you're
seriously adding value like you're not
just refurbing a house changing the
kitchens you know you're getting
planning permission to change it into
flats and stuff i'm trying to be
creative
yeah
i'm inspired how can i apply the blr on
many yeah i'm inspired that's why i love
coming around and looking at your sites
it's inspiring because i'm thinking damn
like i remember when we built some
houses up north and we sold them off we
made about half a million pounds profit
and that was on like six houses that we
built and i'm thinking
regified more than that on one house
damn now i'm trying to do it on each
product that i'm taking that yeah that's
the way to grow always like out of all
the deals which one which you've
completed on which one's been the most
successful or profitable
uh i haven't finished uh
to refinance the last ones but the one
that you visited there with the 450
equity that that's half a million pounds
profit on two flats to about 400 just
shut up half a million house split in
two flats yeah half a million 450.
that's incredible yeah
and how's life changed in the last
couple of years since she started doing
this i mean people think if you have a 7
million property portfolio it can change
your life dramatically i say no
my life is the same i mean okay so yeah
my my net worth is growing out there but
it's not really sitting in my pocket my
life is the same i dress the same my
my life is the same except the feeling
that you know
that
you're building yourself so you live a
pretty simple life
i will say medium medium life not simple
not to the top
something in the middle so what are you
doing when you're making money do a
project and you make half a million quid
i will throw it on the property straight
away she just put reinvest in everything
yeah now
[Music]
the a different situation i need to
think about what i will do if suddenly
half a million will follow me because i
have other people putting money on my
properties so i need to find out to
spend my own money now but i'm sure
we'll find a solution you live a pretty
decent life though i've been around your
house i've seen your car yes you live a
pretty good life what what's next then
for brigitte what's the plan are you
just gonna continue now it's like eight
to ten years
to buy property like like a maniac
that's the goal that's the do you ever
intend to move out of your area or
you're just going to stay on in our area
i'm sure i'm going to need to because
now i'm going to purchase more i'm going
to need to find more deals
so obviously
i can just extend the search area
also around me just to make it a bit
larger so i can find more games talk to
me about that because there's more to it
than just working out
what's the purchase price what's the end
value what's the build cost can i pull
my money out you've also got to think
about if you're keeping it are the
mortgage payments going to be covered
what's the rentability what are my exit
strategies like what are some of the
other things that you're looking at now
it's a very
good question because now when the
entrance went up
some of the properties that was
good cash flowing
last year
now they might not cash flow right
but still
you purchase the property you have
capital appreciation anyway and within
few years
they will drop again
and then you renew the mortgage
everything is just fine do you ever
worry that using other people's money on
your deals and then refinancing do you
ever worry that you're going to be super
leveraged almost like on a knife edge
no because i think that the buy to let
market because it's 25 75 percent is way
more
safe and secure than the the regular
mortgages the people that's true 10 yeah
that's true so obviously the whole
private market will collapse
before it will reach the buy to let
market so if your 7 million pound
portfolio how much of that is mortgaged
and how much of that is your equity so
yeah 75 25. so a couple mail yeah i
guess the first ones that i bought it's
already a little bit different yeah
because it was a big increase in the
pricing of the properties right property
that i bought last year today is 100k
more yeah but it's crazy but we all know
reggie if it keeps going up you'll
refinance again
yeah yes yes yes and keep your 25 in
that should buffer i can't see property
prices are going to drop dramatically
anyway though they might we all know
properties got up they go down they go
up they go down yes but if you don't
intend to sell it who cares i've had
property it'll go down we'll buy more
it's good for us we're buyers isn't it
yeah other properties i bought houses in
like 2009 right
i've had them drop
they're in negative equity if i
my net worth on them is minus
but i don't care i'm holding on them i'm
renting them out i'm enjoying the golden
goose
is eggs every morning for breakfast the
rent's coming in i'll sit on it then
i'll wait a few years then they'll go
back up cool yeah like it doesn't matter
what does matter is you pointed out is
if you buy a house you put down 10
you're living in it you're not getting
any rent
then you're on a knife edge help to buy
you on a knife edge having a job when
wages are staying the same but
everything's going up now you're on a
knife edge yeah i think that i never
been there like that's not something i
except the time i went to work as a
labor that was the first time i was
actually an employee i can't see you
being a great employee
i i was an amazing employee
really yeah hard worker because the hard
work because as a person i'm a manager
so straight away you know i i manage
everything but you're not you're not cut
out to be an employee
no no because i grew up in a house that
everyone are entrepreneurs my mom every
business my father my brothers have a
business we just don't do
employment what would you say to people
that say there's a massive housing
shortage in london
and you're
buying up everything
making all this money
and morally it's not right how does that
fit with you it's not really changed to
anyone who owned
[Music]
this property or that property what
what's different does it make to anyone
there's a housing shortage and you're
buying everything and there's people
that come but i don't live in the whole
20 right so i don't short make more
shortage in the market the houses are
staying in the market that's two
people's homes yeah yeah you don't leave
them there anyway but you're creating
more homes because you're turning one
house into two or three yeah and i put i
i believe that this the stock that i put
in the market
is much more nicer than what you can
find always when i put and it's on zupla
it goes straight away
because it's nice it's brand new it's
how important is it
is mindset in this because i know it's a
lot of this is about training and
formulas and knowing how much things are
going to be will you get planning
there's a lot of hard technical skills
to this business which you have in
abundance
but how important is the mindset
and the attitude of a property investor
i don't look on the small staff
i look on the majority on the big stuff
the important stuff in my calculation
you won't see me now calculate
insurance and
you know 25 pounds for this and 70
pounds it's just not there i'll put 10k
general you know to to be safe and
do everything just quicker go
go to i don't have any business card i
don't
like
fancy names
i don't have a secretary i don't have
office
i don't have i do it all myself
and to be honest i have a lot of free
time well mate i'm inspired what will be
your final words of wisdom to someone
watching this guys just go and do it
just go and do it find great beer deals
that you can pull out hundred percent
out it's a magic by itself then
investors
won't resist it they just that the best
things you can offer for them go find it
and start to do what i'm doing
good advice
i appreciate your friendship beautiful
[Music]